bueno agradezco estar acá estoy
impresionada porque la televisión yo no
veo quién me mira agradezco la presencia
de mi hermana mónica que mi mentora la
que me enseñó a cocinar
acá
yo no quería llorar quiere una pastilla
para aliento pero así soy le gusta bien
y si no también
bueno y mi hija valentina de 16 años que
la dejado ir al colegio porque ya tiene
que escuchar esta historia que ella no
había nacido y muy orgullosa de tener a
mi familia acá de mis amigos bueno todo
comenzó
me tiene que poner el tiempo acá para no
pasarme por favor porque no veo la
pantallita después eso me tiene un poco
nervioso porque soy bien lora no
entonces éste no aparece acá el numerito
va a aparecer
ya está listo todo comenzó cuando
termine el colegio que yo quería
estudiar algo que me llenara tanto la
vida como hacer dulces como mi hermana
me enseñó o yo tengo mucha habilidad con
las manos dio más de agua este don tejo
gordo hago un poco de todo y este cuando
tenía que escoger qué carrera estudiar
yo tenía que escoger una carrera y me
preparé en la academia que puede haber
salido el colegio como correspondía
buenas notas en la academia en el
colegio y cuando iba había escogido esta
universidad que tenía una facultad de
diseño gráfico muy importante mi papá me
dijo no quiero que vayas a esa facultad
diseño gráfico me parece que esta
facultad muy liberal para una niña de 17
años y habiendo salido colegio de monjas
termine en un instituto técnico superior
de mujeres de tres años mi frustración
fue porque yo quería tener un curso
académico de universidad y lo que
conlleva estar en una universidad no
podía hacer nada mi papá pagar los
estudios terminé me gradué con buenas
notas como correspondía tres años de
carrera y me dijo y ahora demuéstrame
que puedes trabajar entregó una agencia
de publicidad y en ese momento también
yo tenía como esta cosa de que soy
hiperactiva y la gente que me conoce
saben que no sé de dónde salió esa
energía yo siempre digo que por la
quinoa que mi mamá me ha dado cuando era
chica yo me tejía mi chompas en la noche
para ponerme al día siguiente para
trabajar y la gente me decía que 'el
indio' son para kindle ha hecho yo teje
me digo como soy comerciante le tejía
hecho más a todo el mundo
pero después no podía más porque era
mucho la demanda entonces puse un aviso
en el periódico y conseguí una señora
efe que ya ante xerez en su casa y hoy
va a toda la semana llevando el material
y los diseños que yo misma le diseñaba y
como no había celular era ir hasta los
conos y a la venia argentina la venia
venezuela y si no nos hablaban por
teléfono fijo porque no había celular
deje la agencia de publicidad y en el
ínterin conocía el que es ahora mi
marido de 32 años hubo plevisani y
cuando mi papá vio que las personas
también un poco es seria que quería
mandarme estudia una maestría fuera yo
dije que no que yo me quedaba y ahí
de ahí nos comprometimos y nos casamos
este año que viene vamos a cumplir 33
años de casados y comenzamos juntos por
esta iniciativa de la aventura del
restaurante tuvimos el restaurante en
una época que había terrorismo escasez
apagones no había agua no había nada yo
iba a la casa mi hermana pues a cocinar
un mus me metí en el restaurante con uno
por una necesidad me quedé un día en la
casa sola tenía miedo me dijo ven al
restaurante y nunca más salí y preparar
los postres porque veía que
necesitábamos una mano femenina y entre
apagones y todos salimos adelante
en una época muy complicada de perú y
después de tres años empezó a venir la
familia primero vino ariana yo me había
casado 23 años a los 26 tuve arianna que
ahora tiene 28 años luego vino camila
que tendría 26 de divino maría valentín
y está no estaba todavía en el en la
película y en el año 2000 tuvimos la
noticia más nefasta que una madre puede
tener que nos dijeron que camila a mi
hija tenía cáncer era la dimensión
desconocida para mí yo no sabía nada yo
veía sangre me desmayaba tuve que
aprender enfermería a saber lo que es un
catéter a sacar sangre por el heno por
jim para las defensas subirme a estados
unidos a buscar tratamiento alternativo
para mi hija y hacer todo lo que
conllevaba por poder salvar la vida de
esa niña mi familia me apoyó
inclusivo fuimos a un trasplante de
médula cuando pensábamos que ellas y dax
ante el trasplante cuando pensamos que
camila ya estaba sana salí encinta de la
linda valentina y lo que más celebró
camila es traer al mundo estuvo en el
parto conmigo con valentina y de ahí
recayó camila estuvimos que nos eeuu por
un año entonces luego hicimos el
trasplante de médula el primero en el
mundo conservo made you win para camila
y todo con conocimiento y también le
dijimos mamá vamos vamos a hacer todo lo
posible para curar mi hija maría de 5
años en ese entonces fue la donante de
las células madres una valentía que
valentía la de maría me sacaron la
sangre para que curar a su hermana
lamentablemente esto ya sabe que el
trasplante pro funcionó y camila
falleció hace 16 años en ese momento mis
hijas me preguntaron una tarde puede que
vinimos del cementerio mamá y ahora que
vamos a hacer nada le dije vamos a
continuar como familia y vamos a seguir
adelante porque camila una niña muy
especial y la gente que ha conocido sabe
que nunca quería verme triste salíamos
de tratamiento nos íbamos al cinema me
iba un pack y para ella era súper alegre
bailaba salsa era linda dije no temas yo
le he prometido a camila hacer
para los niños que no pueden tener la
suerte de ir a navidad con su familia
que no tienen los medios para curarse
cuando íbamos a neoplásicas por
emergencias ya mamá porque yo tengo
tanto y esta gente no tiene y me dijo
mantenemos que hacer algo yo tenía que
hacer algo que fuera de su mamá no salir
a buscar nada después de camila falleció
me ofrecieron hacer el programa de
televisión y yo lo acepté porque dije
será una terapia para mí
y lo acepté con mucho gusto porque dije
como yo estaba en el hospital viendo
tanto y lo sacan con la espátula cuando
cocinan bien sea el día que yo tengo un
programa en televisión voy a sacar todo
con espátula que le ha puesto la rabiosa
voy a hacer esto voy a meter en el horno
siempre soñaba y los sueños se tocan
porque así es la vida decir me pasaba a
mí en la vida y justo acepté el programa
de televisión y yo tenía este pendiente
de hacer algo mío dije voy a hacer un
libro o abrir la caja de pandora con el
libro famoso para que la gente tenga un
libro y fui donde un médico quien te lo
va a distribuir cómo hacer y busque a
los mejores profesionales del medio por
como yo soy diseñadora gráfica herrera y
repostera por pasión dije voy a apuntar
a lo mejor
fotógrafos estilos todo y no había
manera yo no sabía cómo acceder a estos
medios para poder hacer el libro y de la
nada es de lo mágico del cuento me llama
una chica que mi vida había visto que
era la gerente de productos nuevos de
una editorial muy grande me dijo mi hija
que ha visto en la tele y dice que tiene
potencial para hacer un libro y tú sabes
no se vino corriendo el restaurante que
teníamos en bonilla y cruzamos a la
acera del frente para ver quién era el
que había hecho este libro de post desde
la cocina peruana que es precioso y dijo
yo lo he hecho en la editorial y digo
acá tengo mi machote pero como sabes no
entiendo yo creo que camila hizo esto
posible porque de la nada yo no la
conocía y ha sido mi editora de 54
libros que he hecho y esta chica pues
creyó en mí y me dijo este vamos a hacer
esto hay que hacer una lista de los
posibles auspiciadores porque no tenía
nada de plata
todo mundo había que pagarle había que
con costó en el libro al primero
auspiciador que fuimos de la lista nos
tomó el proyecto y cuando le digan a
nadie por favor y se hizo el famoso
libro rojo que eran que mi color
favorito y todos estos profesionales
desarrollaron este libro y se hizo justo
antes para dos días antes del día y la
madre y sin primeros 10.000 libros
pensando de que nos iba a vender yo
estaba en mi casa mirando el techo con
ataque de pánico dije muchas cosas de
dios mío que me quemé metido y me llama
el gerente comercial y me dice sandra
hemos vendido todos los libros en
mediodía que hacemos
entonces yo digo es ha sido cam y la
campanita con sus pollitos mágicos he
hecho esto realidad y después de tantos
años he hecho ya 54 publicaciones de
ellas muchos beneficios otras para
enseñar el perú al mundo donde gracias
al libro el postre peruano y al libro de
moquegua me gana 22 premios gourmand en
europa y ahora mi libro de conventos
un poco un poco sin saber ni leer ni
escribir ahora me involucre tanto en
esos libros que es un libro de conventos
me he metido a todos los conventos de
claustro el perú hemos ido ayacucho
arequipa cusco todo lo que hemos y me
dejaban entrar solamente la monjita
porque ven mi programa de televisión
este libro se ha ido a europa y está
finalista y me tengo que ir a macao en
china a recibir un premio en julio
porque parece que va a ganar también
entonces sería 3
pero pero todo esto se ha mezclado por
salir en la televisión ser imagen de
marcas los libros todo ha venido porque
yo creo que camina donde está me cuida y
me manda esos regalos de agradecimiento
a que siempre cumplo las promesas hoy
chan corona nunca dejó pendientes y eso
me hizo acordar una cosa muy bella qué
es lo que más importa en este té cuando
yo estaba en el hospital con camila y
fuimos para el segundo tratamiento
cuando ella había recaído y tenía que
hacer el trasplante
camila quería comer como en su casa como
buena plevisani tiene que comer rico su
salsa hecho en el momento sus pastas sus
dulces todo yo cocinaba en el hospedaje
del hospital y todos los olores se iban
y todos los niños venían como el fan
triste de hamelin
y le decía nada le decía a caminar
camila me puedes invitar a almorzar y
camila claro mi mamita va para mi cocina
para todos
y yo y yo era feliz porque traíamos a
todos estos niños que lo único que
querían bajoneado es un tratamiento era
comer rico el olor y se juntaba en yo
escuchaba mientras que cocinaba y le
servían los platos los cuentos que me
han hecho esto ese camino era feliz de
poder invitar a todos estos niños y la
habana después vinieron las mamás y los
papás y la mesa de seis se convirtió en
25 y para mí era la terapia más
maravillosa del mundo tener que
preocuparme nada más en darle de comer
bien esta gente que me pedía las recetas
y yo le explicaba sin secreto sin nada
les ya esto tienes que hacer esto te va
a salir bien y me hacían la salsa al día
siguiente iglesia que bien porque me has
explicado bien porque no tiene secretos
porque tú quieres que a mí me salga como
a ti y ahí me di cuenta de que uno
queriendo ser como es sin secretos como
es la vida no devolverle a la vida todo
lo que me ha dado la lección de vida que
yo he tenido por está en amor profundo
de mi hija cambia
y de poderle dar lo mejor y recibir este
agradecimiento de ustedes que son mi
público de comprar mis publicaciones
encontrarme con gente que me ha traído
libros para firmar y poder comunicar y
poder decir lo que yo voy descubriendo
porque yo soy autodidacta y ahora de una
escuela de cocina soy diseñadora gráfica
de profesión
y soy cocinera por vocación y por pasión
pero además me dado cuenta que yo puedo
comunicar y que puedo inspirar a la
gente diciendo solamente la verdad y eso
se demuestra en la gente que me
encuentro en la calle y todo lo que
recibo de ustedes que son una maravilla
con las publicaciones que yo cuento
hasta el último detalle para que te
quede bien la gente que viene y me ha
dicho que gracias a los alfajores que le
enseñaba hacer un pago a la universidad
sus hijos
gente que hace cafeterías y que me
agradece todo esto no de este
desprendimiento que yo tengo pero porque
yo tengo que agradecer la vida de
haberme enseñado y vaya podido ver en
estos momentos de camila y de toda mi
vida en general que el amor infinito no
tiene precio y hay cosas en la vida que
no se pagan porque él
invitando a toda esta gente a comer con
todos los chicos del hospital y poderles
enseñar a los padres cómo cocinar les y
ver la felicidad de estos niños que
venían bajoneados con su tratamiento y
que solamente estaban felices a comer un
peruvian cookie que eran los alfajores y
poderles enseñar todo eso cada vez que
yo escribo un libro soy feliz cada vez
que toma una foto de mi postre porque
todo lo que ustedes ven en mi libros
está cocinado por mí no hay fotos
styling no hay alguien que viene lo hace
lo hago yo saco del horno soy feliz y
esa felicidad creo que se transmite y
eso lo que es mi misión en la vida poder
hacer feliz a la gente que está pasando
lo mismo que yo paso porque yo todos los
días y oro todos los estoy llorando
ahorita todos los días
no a veces no me quiero despertar en la
mañana que digo no tengo mis hijas son
una maravilla les he dejado estudiar lo
que quieran
ahí está la materia na se ha graduado de
antropología visual que no sabía qué
cosa era
le va muy bien mi hija maría que es la
que tiene 21 años estudia finanzas y
ahora está trabajando muy bien y mi hija
valentina va a terminar el colegio y
tendrá que hacer lo que ella quiera y
poder que sean felices porque cuando uno
hace lo que uno verdaderamente quiere
transmite felicidad y la felicidad por
eso es bueno donde la gente se me acerca
y me dice sandra cuál es su secreto
haces todo restaurantes en conductora de
televisión libros mamá esposa todo yo me
pongo poco nerviosa porque no sé esta
energía que yo tengo debe ser que dios
me la ha dado para hacer una misión en
la vida tengo que entender que la gente
se va hay gente que se va antes hay
gente que se va después todos nos vamos
a ir y yo puedo vivir y despertarme
todos los días a pesar de que a veces no
quiero salir de mi cama de que camila se
fue antes porque me ha dejado una
lección de vida
y sabe muy bien que tengo la fortaleza y
la salud gracias a dios me acabo de
chequear todos las cosas médicas
imposibles de la vida hasta el pelo me
he quedado
estoy sana buena para seguir adelante y
creo que es la misión que yo tengo hoy
por hoy de ser una inspiradora y no
quiero creerme de que le puedo gustar a
todo el mundo sé que hay gente que no me
quiere y hay gente que si me quiere y
tengo que aprender también a vivir con
eso porque también será expuesta
mediáticamente es un costo muy alto que
ustedes tienen que saber que yo llevo y
quien es fácil o sea estar para acá
sabiendo todo lo que sucede alrededor de
una persona mediática no es fácil pero
quiero que sepan de que el secreto más
grande es andrés que no tiene secretos
lo que ustedes ven es no hay otra sandra
y nunca lo va a ver y espero que sea así
para siempre porque eso lo que me hace
ser feliz encontrarme con la gente en el
supermercado de que me pide una receta y
yo se la doy me quedo horas explicándole
para que le salga porque cuando le sale
pues me mandan foto de mí se me salió
igual que usted no medios ustedes dime
sandra entonces del usted pasan a
sandrita entonces yo soy feliz con eso y
eso es lo que me hace seguir viviendo y
cuando me dijeron para estar en un tête
que mi marido sea que vean ustedes y mis
hijas me hicieron amar no puedo creer y
después han escuchado todos los
testimonios maravillosos
yo digo qué cosa me queda a mí entonces
yo lo único que puedo decir es que ésta
es la única sandra no hay otra no hay
secretos en mi vida y la verdad es que
yo soy feliz y que gracias a mis recetas
a mi repostería a mi familia a mi
deporte que se me fue a correr a las 6
de la mañana porque estaba muy nerviosa
estar acá y la verdad que todo eso
agradezco la vida y yo siempre digo que
yo le tengo que devolver a la vida todos
los beneficios que me da y todas las
alegrías que me dan a ver a pesar de
haber pasado esta lección tan dura y
nefasta que nos ha pasado pero que nos
ha unido como familia y que yo todos los
días de la vida digo que extraño mis
hijas soy mamá gallina ustedes se
supieran los gallinas que eso de mamá
siempre recoja a mis hijas del
aeropuerto siempre estoy ahí para ellas
y siempre se burlan de que la mami es la
mamá gallina esta es la única sangre que
hay sin secretos y tienen sandra para
rato muchas gracias
[Aplausos]